CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I'd like
us to do two things.
The first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
graph the curve
r equals 1 plus
cosine theta over 2,
for theta between 0 and
4 pi, and we're going
to graph it in the xy-plane.
And then after we've
done that, we're
going to take a look at some
components of that curve
and we're going to calculate
the area of some components that
close up.
So what I'd like you to do
first is get a good picture
of this curve, in the xy-plane.
I'll give you a little
while to do that.
So why don't you
pause the video,
get a good picture
of that curve,
then come back when you're
ready and I'll show you
how I graph it, and then we'll
get into these area problems.
OK.
Welcome back.
So the goal, again, was to graph
a certain curve described by r
and theta, but in the xy-plane.
For theta between
0 and pi over 4.
And when I do these
problems, we want
to make sure that we understand
how r depends on theta.
That's sort of the main
goal to graph this curve.
So what I do,
actually, is I look
at this not in the
xy-plane, which
was what I said to
do in the problem,
but I first look at it in what
we see as the r, theta plane.
And what we mean
by that is we're
going to graph this just like
we would if this variable was x
and this variable was y.
So we move out of what we know
about how r relates to x and y,
and how theta
relates to x and y,
and we just look at
how r relates to theta.
So let me draw that
first and we'll
see if we can sort of
understand what I mean by that,
and then we'll put that
picture, use that curve
to put that into the xy-plane.
OK.
So, the first thing
we do is I'm going
to let this be the theta-axis
and this be the r-axis.
And let's look at--
I want to write down over here
what the equation is so I don't
have to keep turning around.
So again, this is
not, I don't want
to think about this
as the xy-plane.
Because in the
xy-plane, theta has
certain values at
each point that
are fixed based on the angle.
But now I'm letting theta
vary in this direction,
and r is varying
in this direction.
And my theta, I said,
was between 0 and pi
over 4-- I'm sorry,
not pi over 4.
4*pi.
0 and 4*pi.
pi over 4 would be a very
small component of this
that I'm interested in.
And let's think
about what happens,
what kind of transformations
have been done
to the normal cosine function.
So if I took the
normal cosine function
and I take it-- instead
of cosine theta,
I look it cosine theta
over 2, what that's doing
is that's stretching
it horizontally out.
So think about the period of
the cosine function usually is
2*pi.
But notice what happens when
I put in 2*pi for theta,
I'm getting cosine of pi.
If I want to get cosine of 2*pi,
I have to let theta go to 4*pi,
which is why I'm letting
theta be between 0 and 4*pi.
So dividing the input value
by 2 doubles your period.
So the period is now 4*pi.
So to get all the way through,
I'm going to have to go up
to 4*pi.
So let me just make a 2*pi here,
and this is about a 4*pi here.
So here's around 3 pi,
and here's around pi.
So that now, instead of
the usual cosine function,
it's going to take twice as
long to get all the way through.
That's one thing we know.
What else have we done to
the usual cosine function?
We've moved it up by 1.
And so instead of starting
out when your input is 0,
starting out at height 1,
when you're input is 0,
you start out at
height 1 plus 1.
You start out at height 2.
So in fact, this function,
let me point out,
it's going to start at
2, which means it also
is going to end over here.
Because it's periodic,
it's going to end at 2.
And let's think about
what else we know.
We know that the usual
cosine function goes down
to negative 1.
But I've added 1 to it, so
now it only goes down to 0.
OK?
Hopefully that makes sense.
Maybe I should even-- hmm.
I don't want to draw
the actual cosine
function again right on here.
But let me draw the regular
cosine function here.
So we have it,
the regular cosine
function-- because I
keep talking about it--
does something like this.
It goes at 1 here, and
it's at 1 again here.
And so it's at minus 1 at pi.
And so, very roughly, it
looks something like this.
Right?
So I keep referencing
the cosine function,
so this is the part
I'm referencing.
So we have to stretch it by
2, and then shift it up by 1.
And so we see what
was at pi, negative 1,
I'm now going to be at 2*pi, 0.
And then where do
these points go?
This was pi over 2.
The x-value is
going to be doubled.
I'm going to be at pi, and the
y-value is going to go up by 1.
So I'm at (pi, 1) and (3*pi, 1).
And so the curve will
look something like this.
I'm not an expert here,
but hopefully that
looks something like
the cosine function.
But with a stretch and a shift.
So that is the curve r equals
1 plus cosine theta over 2
in what we consider
the r, theta plane.
So theta is varying
in this direction
and r is varying
in this direction.
But how do I transfer
that to the xy-plane?
That's the real
point that I want
to make about this problem.
So let's look at what's
happening in the xy-plane.
So this will be x
and this will be y.
Let's pick some points and try
to figure out what's happening.
So where is this point?
This is the point
zero comma two.
When theta is 0, r equals 2.
Where is theta equal
to 0 in this picture?
It's in the x-direction.
Right?
That's theta equals 0,
and also 2*pi and 4*pi.
Any multiple of 2*pi, theta
is pointing in this direction.
And r equals 2 there.
So in a strange twist,
this is the point (2, 0)
on the x, y plane.
But that's no going to,
that's just a coincidence, OK?
Don't think, oh, I'm just going
to flip the values everywhere.
That's not going to happen.
OK?
Actually, and also,
before I make a mistake,
I'm going to make this
a little bit bigger.
I want it to be bigger.
So I don't want this to be 2.
I want this to be 1.
I'm going to make this (2, 0).
I want to have a
little bigger picture.
OK.
So it's going to be (2, 0) at
theta equals 0 and r equal 2.
Is it ever hit this point again?
Well, it is.
And it's going to hit that point
again because it's periodic
and I've gone out to 4*pi.
If I rotate all the way
around, I'm at 2*pi for theta.
If I rotate all the way around
again I'm at 4*pi for theta,
and my radius there is 2, also.
So this (2, 0) happens again
when I have this point.
So it's going to close up.
OK.
And then what else happens?
Well, as theta is
rotating, let's
take theta between 0 and pi.
theta rotates from 0
to pi going like this.
Notice what's happening
to the r-value.
The r-value is going
from 2 down to 1.
Now, I'm not going
to be totally exact,
but-- here's minus 1,
OK, in the xy-plane.
I'm not going to
be totally exactly,
but this curve is
going to look something
like-- there's 2-- it's going
to look something like-- oops,
I overshot, we'll make
that negative 1-- something
like this.
And what's the point?
The point is that I start
at radius 2, and by the time
I get to theta equals
pi I've gone down.
And so my radius is 1.
This has radius 1 and angle pi.
So that represents
this part of the curve.
That's this part of the curve.
Now, what's nice
about this drawing
is that we know this
part of the curve
and this part of the curve
should look exactly the same.
So once I've drawn half of this,
I'm going to know everything.
Once I've gone from 0 to 2*pi, I
can just reflect it, basically.
We'll see what I mean
by reflect in this case,
but the same radii are
happening again and some sort
of symmetric fashion.
OK.
So we've got 0 to pi.
Now what happens
between pi and 2*pi?
Notice pi to 2*pi in the theta
direction on the xy-plane is I
start in this direction-- I
don't know if you can see that,
let me come over to this side--
I start in this direction
for pi, and I'm
going to rotate down.
This is 3*pi over
2, and this is 2*pi.
Those are my angles.
So what are my radii?
Well, I start at radius 1
and I'm going to radius 0.
And so what happens is I'm
coming through this negative 1
and I'm coming around, and
then by the time I get--
it's going to be
something like this--
by the time I get to
2*pi, my radius is 0.
Now just to make sure this
curve makes sense to you,
you could pick a place, an
angle, maybe like right here.
I don't know if
that's easy to see,
but maybe that
angle right there.
That angle is between
3*pi over 2 and 2*pi.
Is there positive radius there?
Yeah, there is
positive radius there.
So in fact, this curve does
come into this fourth quadrant
here and then curve back in.
OK?
It does curve back in.
All right.
So then what happens
between 2*pi and 3*pi?
OK.
Hopefully this picture
is clear so far.
I'm going to come back
to the other side.
OK.
What happens between
2*pi and 3*pi?
2*pi, we're here.
And 3*pi, we're back
over here again.
And notice that the radius is
going to be doing the same kind
of growth that it did between
2*pi and 3*pi as it did decay
from pi to 2*pi.
OK?
Because the radii now,
there's a symmetry
with how the radii behave.
So from 2*pi to 3*pi, I start
off with radius 0 and I have
a small radius.
And then once I get
to 3*pi over here,
I'm going to have
radius 1 again.
I'm going to be at
radius 1, which is going
to correspond to this point.
So I'm going to have exactly
the same picture, which
is dangerous because I
probably would do it wrong.
But I'll try and draw it this
way and then talk about it.
Hopefully that looks
about the same.
So this curve coming through
here was from pi to 2*pi.
This curve coming through
here was from to 2*pi to 3*pi.
And then to finish it off, 3*pi
to 4*pi is going to look like
this curve here.
So I come through-- ooh, this
is where it starts to get really
dangerous, but let's say
that's pretty close--
so there's my 3*pi to 4*pi.
It's again, the
same growth the way
it was decaying
between 0 and pi.
So this is your picture in the
xy-plane of the curve r equals
1 plus cosine theta over 2.
Now, we haven't calculated
any area problems, yet.
So what I'd like us to do is
I'm going to shade two regions,
and I want us to just write
down the integral form
to find the area for
each of these regions.
So the first region of
interest is the pink region.
I'm going to ask us to find
the area of the pink region,
and then I'm going to ask us
to find the area of everything
else, the blue region.
So let's think about
how to do that.
And I think I'm going to have
to come over to the other side
to write down the integrals, but
I'll be coming back and forth.
So just to remind
you, what you saw
in lecture was that dA is equal
to r squared over 2 d theta.
That's what dA is.
And so this is going to
be an integral in theta,
and we know what r is
as a function of theta.
And so if I want
to find-- actually,
I should even use my
colors appropriately.
I should say, the
pink area is going
to be equal to an integral.
And I'm going to
write the r squared.
I know what r squared is.
It's 1 plus cosine
theta over 2 squared,
and then an over 2 d theta.
And then what is
important about this?
It's our bounds.
Right?
Our bounds are what's important.
And so let's go back and
let's look at our picture.
What are the bounds on
theta for the pink region?
So where does that pink
region start and stop?
And maybe we even need to
look at this top graph, also.
So if we think about
it, we went from 0 to pi
to get this outer curve.
So how do we get
the inner curve?
The inner curve started at
theta equals pi, went to here,
went to here-- that
was theta equals 3*pi.
So it went all the
way from pi to 3*pi.
Now, if you're paying
good attention,
you can say, well, Christine,
we know that this region is
totally symmetric.
So why don't I just take
the area from pi to 2*pi
and multiply it by 2?
And you can.
You can do it either way.
So you can either take the
integral from all the way from
pi to 3*pi, which corresponds
to starting at this angle,
going all the way around,
and coming back to there,
which takes you all the
way around this curve.
Or you can go from pi to
2*pi and multiply that by 2.
So let me come back and
let me write that down.
It's either pi to 3*pi, this,
or you just write it as integral
from pi to 2*pi.
And if I multiply this
by 2, the 2 drops out.
The 2 in the
denominator drops out.
I'm not going to solve
this problem for you,
but I do want to point out the
kinds of terms you would have.
You would have a constant
term when you square this.
You would have a term that
was 2 cosine theta over 2,
which is easy to integrate
by a u-substitution.
And then you would have
a cosine squared theta
over 2, which you'd want
to use the double angle
formula or the
half angle formula
that you've seen used to
manipulate these integrals that
involve just a cosine
squared or a sine squared.
So that would be your strategy.
OK, now let's look
at the blue area.
OK.
So to find the
blue area, again, I
know all that matters
is really the bounds.
We're going to see we have
to do a little extra work.
But this is our first setup.
And now let's go
look at the bounds.
OK.
So we go back to the curve.
All right.
What is the blue area?
Well, the blue area,
that's a little harder.
So let's see what happens.
If I were to take theta from
0 to pi, what would happen?
I would not only pick
up the blue area,
but I'd pick up this
pink stuff inside.
But I don't want the pink stuff.
I just want the blue stuff.
So what am I going to have to
do to find the blue area just,
say, from 0 up to pi?
I'm going to have to find
the area from 0 to pi,
and then I'm going to
have to subtract off
the area of this component.
OK?
But we know,
actually, how to find
the area of this component.
OK.
So hopefully this makes sense.
Because let's think about,
when I'm finding area,
I'm going from the
origin and I'm coming out
and I have the radius out there.
So when I integrate this
dA from 0 to pi for theta,
I'm picking up
pieces that come out,
little sectors that
come out like this
between pi over 2 and pi.
So I'm getting more area
than I want if I just
let theta go between 0 and pi.
So I have to
calculate all of it,
and then I have to take
away the extra stuff.
OK.
So the blue area is
actually the bigger area
subtracting the smaller area.
And so how am I
going to write this?
If we come back over, I'm
just going to take 2 times
this whole thing.
So I'm going to
take 2 times this.
And I know I have to
integrate it from 0 to pi.
And I'm taking 2 times because
it's symmetric, remember.
And then I'm going to subtract
track off this one that's 2
times the thing from pi to 2*pi.
Now, you might say,
well, Christine,
the pink stuff I'm interested
in between 0 and pi is actually
theta between not pi and
2*pi, but 2*pi and 3*pi.
But again, there's all this
symmetry in the problem.
So it doesn't really matter.
But if you're a
stickler, I guess
I'll even write it this
way just to make sure.
So I'll write it as 2*pi to 3*pi
so that everyone's very happy.
OK?
So again, what do we do?
These 2's divide out.
So from 0 to pi of
r squared d theta,
that's going to give me the
area of the blue plus the pink.
And then 2*pi to 3*pi of 1
plus cosine over theta over 2
squared d theta is going to
give me the area of the pink.
So the blue plus the
pink is over here,
and then the pink is over here.
So when I subtract that
off I just get the blue.
OK.
Let me, again, just
go back one more time
and point out what we
did at the very beginning
to remind us what was happening.
And then I will finish.
So let's come back over here.
So the idea was to graph
this curve that was
in r is a function of theta.
And I was supposed to
understand what that
looked like in the xy-plane.
And so my trick was to take
the relationship between r
and theta and graph
that explicitly in an r,
theta plane-- so
I let theta vary
in the horizontal
direction and r
vary in the vertical direction--
and I can do that very easily.
And then translate
that into the xy-plane.
So my curve, again,
went the big part,
the little part here, little
part here, big part here.
That was the order.
So if you need arrows on
it, this was the order.
And then once I had that,
the problem was about areas.
And there was a lot of
symmetry in this problem,
but the main point
I wanted to show
was just knowing where your
theta starts and stops is not
enough to determine
an area of a region,
if that region is excluding some
part that would be potentially
counted twice.
So that was the reason I wanted
you to calculate not just
the pink area, but also see
that the blue is not from theta
from 0 to pi, but you have to
subtract off this extra stuff
that you counted.
And I guess that is
where I will stop.